hey guys embarrass going to show just a
few moves that are surprisingly easy to
do but very impressive looking in the
world of a curio guy and I'm no expert
experts or people like kiplyn here at
kiplyn ki plin n on all the socials
jason Nemer
jenny of courses with a chemical
founders of AcroYoga
and many others are the pros but that's
why I'm showing you this because these
do not require you to be a pro alright
so the first is going to be a walk over
to throne so this is something that
people have a lot of trepidation about
getting into a handstand so Kipling can
feel free to add some color as needed
but I'm going to show you what is
actually an entrance into a routine of
any type that is surprisingly easy to do
so we'll show it and then I can sort of
add some thoughts first thing you'll
notice is that I'm not like this getting
ready for it because it looks terrible
alright and you learn these things over
time all I'm going to do is sort of be
sitting like this where my legs are
going to straddle pike up to here and
that's what it's going to look like and
we'll show it it looks like
but alright and then we're in throwing
then we can do fun stuff like pop the
bird okay okay now that's not the part
we're going to cover we're just going to
cover the walk over so let's come down
all rights with the walk over what I
want to point out is that I'm actually
aiming to land right about here if you
go right for the glute when she actually
sits your foots going to slip so you're
kind of aiming right here in terms of
the mail or not necessarily mail the
base portion of it Kipling any thoughts
on the actual handstand any pointers
there okay so the flier should have
their hands close to my hips you don't
wanna be too far out obviously better to
be a little too close than too far away
and in general a lot of folks from there
thinking of handstands there different
ways to do it
start with shoulder-width and you can
either either have your middle fingers
pointing forward or index fingers
pointing forward you can play with what
works for you
and getting a little bit of extension
can help quite a bit with slowing things
down it's actually kind of a fun drill
you do handstands against the wall start
off kick up and then really push push to
get that extension and break it'll slow
you down so let's show it one more time
and then we won't do a few more okay so
you see them right here now what I'm
going to do is hook on top of the feet
she's going to dorsiflex pull or toes
back and then just sit right up boom now
from here since this looks kind of weird
you put the feet right on the shins and
that allows you to do all sorts of thing
you actually rest pretty easily from
here and then at a later point in time
you can do something like this which is
just the one-two
catching the bird notice when I catch my
feet are pointed out there are many
different ways to do this I find that to
be the least violent against my flyer
lots of Bend and then kind of popping up
and then placing the feet back to
parallel almost like an Olympic
weightlifter coming up from a clean and
like popping it up to get their hands
into proper position very similar and I
would suggest staying away from the pop
to bird for now but if you're at a level
where that makes sense
placing a lot of weight on the hands and
allows the flyer if they have good body
words to kind of break themselves on the
way down so it's not just a uncontrolled
freefall okay and that is the walk over
to thrown de Burgh thanks for watching
everybody I would love to share more
videos with you if you would like to see
them please subscribe right here and I
will get to making more for you